this is a production of Cornell
University
so we previously looked at allé brusca
type cultivar and how it grew and this
is what we call Vitis vinifera so this
is one of the classic European wine
grapes and then provided we get them to
grow upwards because those tend to like
to grow up it's a much smaller canopy
than the libretto and so what we can
then do is son with the shoots between
those touch wires and hold them in place
and and put them right up to the top
here so when we looked at the Concord
the fruit was up here when we look at
the Venera the fruit is usually down
here and this is Cabernet Franc and I
can identify it as Kevin in front
because it's got its got some very lobed
Melissa it's five lobe leaf and then
Cabernet Franc usually has this this
little tooth right here in the sinus
this is the sinus of the leaf and that's
how we can identify it reasonably easily
when we look down at the fruit you can
see that the clusters are significantly
smaller than they were on the Concord
that we looked at and if I take a berry
here and I try to see if it's gonna slip
skin it doesn't basically it juices all
over and that's not a slip skin cultivar
so that's how I can identify this as
Cabernet Franc and this as a Vitis
vinifera cultivar
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu